damit ist der Gesetzentwurf angenommen
das Abstimmungsergebnis wurde noch im
Saal von Besuchern und Abgeordneten
gefeiert
wir sind total spannender und
historischer Tag
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch 2017
des Tag für die Ehe für alle
Bürgerlichen Gesetzbuch steht jetzt die
Ehe wird von zwei Personen verschiedenen
oder gleichen Geschlechts auf Lebenszeit
geschlossen viele Paare haben die
Möglichkeit genutzt bis Ende 2021 haben
65.600 Menschen gleichen Geschlechts
geheiratet doch bis heute wird über die
Ehe für alle diskutiert deswegen finde
ich diese Ehe für alle auch wirklich
ein wahnsinnig wichtigen und richtigen
Schritt und habe das Gefühl dass da
einfach vielen Menschen mit solchen
Einstellungen was verbaut wird die nie
was falsch gemacht haben außer ein
Menschen zu lieben ich glaube
tatsächlich dass die Ehe so wie die
Bibel davon spricht nur zwischen Mann
und Frau existieren kann fünf Jahre nach
Einführung der Ehe für alle fragen wir
uns wie ist die Lage von Schwulen und
Lesben in Deutschland das setze ich in
den Kontext hallo ich bin aminata belli
um herauszufinden wie weit wir mit der
Gleichberechtigung wirklich sind gucken
wir uns jetzt drei wichtige Bereiche an
wie sieht es in der Gesellschaft aus was
ist mit dem Berufsleben und wie sieht es
tatsächlich aus gibt es die volle
Gleichberechtigung starten wir auf der
zwischenmenschlichen Ebene mit der
Gleichberechtigung in der Gesellschaft
die Akzeptanz für homo und bisexuelle
Menschen scheint groß bei einer Umfrage
2019 stimmten beispielsweise 88% der
Befragten in Deutschland zu das schwule
lesbische und bisexuelle Menschen die
gleichen Rechte haben sollten wie
heterosexuelle Menschen gleichzeitig
sind Form der Abwertung aber immer noch
weit verbreitet es gibt okay aber im
Fernsehen auch an Zeitlang kam dauernd
dauernd nur mit denen Homos wie sie sich
geküsst haben dann kriege ich so einen
Hals noch krasser waren Aussagen in den
70er Jahren was halten sie von
Homosexuellen
[Gelächter]
das ist was scheußliches
und vor genau 50 Jahren also 1972
demonstrierten in Münster Homosexuelle
das erste Mal in Deutschland dafür sich
öffentlich zu ihrer Homosexualität
bekennen zu können ohne
gesellschaftliche geächtet zu werden
oder rechtliche Konsequenzen zu tragen
wie zum Beispiel ihren Job zu verlieren
oder der Uni verwiesen zu werden später
beginnt dann die Tradition der Paraden
zum Christopher Street Day die
Diskussion über AIDS hat auch bewirkt
dass freier über Sexualität gesprochen
wird
Ängste werden metallbar Wünsche brauchen
nicht mehr heimlich zu sein Tabuisierung
hilft nicht weiter
Christopher Street Day in Berlin eine
ausgelassene Parade von Schwulen und
Lesben und eine Demonstration für mehr
Rechte und gegen neonazistische
Tendenzen seit Jahren setzt sich die
lgbtqi+ Community für mehr Akzeptanz ein
lgbtqi+ ist eine Abkürzung aus dem
Englischen für lesbische Schwule
Bisexuelle Transsexuelle queere und
intersexuelle Menschen aber die Realität
zeigt auch heute dazu noch berichten
Homosexuelle von Angriffen und der Angst
davor im Alltag diskriminiert zu werden
ja also wenn ich heute irgendwie
rausgehe und beispielsweise mit meinem
Freund oder öffentlichen Freund habe
irgendwie Hand in Hand gehe dann ist das
schon irgendwie komisch oder ich mache
es teilweise auch schon gar nicht mehr
weil ich irgendwie auch so ein bisschen
Angst habe davor ja dass irgendjemand
rechts aus der Straße aus der
Straßenecke kommt oder das sieht und ja
ein auf einen zukommt und einen
irgendwie Gewalt an droht oder
vielleicht auch zusammenschlagen will
gibt es ja oft genug leider immer noch
und das schlägt sich auch klar in den
Zahlen nieder die registrierten
Straftaten aufgrund der sexuellen
Orientierung sind 2021 deutlich mehr
geworden sie sind um 50% auf 870 Delikte
gestiegen expert:innen befürchten aber
dass die Dunkelziffer noch viel höher
ist auch in diesem Jahr gab es
queerfeindliche Angriffe in Münster
endete einer tödlich ein 25-jähriger
transsexueller der in Münster bei einer
Parade zum Christopher Street Day vor
knapp einer Woche niedergeschlagen
worden war ist seinen schweren
Verletzungen erlegen er war dazwischen
gegangen als ein Unbekannter am Rande
der Veranstaltung mit Lesben Schwulen
bisexuellen und weiteren Gruppen mehrere
Frauen beschimpft hatte eine Studie von
2020 bestätigt Öffentlichkeit Freizeit
und der private Bereich sind die
Lebensbereiche in den Menschen am
häufigsten aufgrund ihrer sexuellen
Orientierung oder ihrer
Geschlechtsidentität diskriminiert
werden kommen wir zum zweiten Punkt der
Gleichberechtigung im Berufsleben
eigentlich verbietet das Allgemeine
Gleichbehandlungsgesetz Diskriminierung
wegen der sexuellen Identität im
Arbeitsleben die Realität ist aber 30
Prozent der lgbtqi+ Menschen erfahren
Diskriminierung im Arbeitsleben
verschiedene Studien zeigen außerdem
dass sich viele Beschäftigte gegenüber
ihren kolleg:innen nicht outen oder
verschlossen mit ihrer sexuellen
Orientierung umgehen er weiß dass der
Wahlkampf mit harten Bandagen geführt
werden wird und so kommt wo bereit mit
einem überraschenden Bekenntnis einer
möglichen pressekamp zuvor
damit auch keine Irritationen hochkommen
liebe Genossinnen und Genossen ich sage
es euch auch und wer es noch nicht
gewusst hat ich bin schwul und das ist
auch gut so liebe Genossen und Genossen
ich hatte mir eigentlich auch
vorgenommen in diesem Amt so gut wie gar
nicht über meine Homosexualität zu reden
weil es für mich so banal und und
unwichtig auch ist und dann merkt man
aber natürlich es spielt in der
Öffentlichkeit eine Rolle und natürlich
weiß ich auch wie viele Formen von
Diskriminierung ist immer noch gibt die
andere Leute viel mehr betreffen als
mich wenn man schwul ist kann man kein
guter Fußballer sein nicht stimmt so
nicht weil ich das eben auch bewiesen
habe unsere Recherchen haben gezeigt
dass Homosexuelle in Deutschland
eigentlich schon immer befürchteten
wegen ihrer sexuellen Orientierung
benachteiligt zu werden in einem Beitrag
aus dem zdf-archiv äußerten sie sich
deshalb auch nur anonym man Beruf den
ich jetzt ergreifen werde geht da hinaus
dass ich Menschen zu führen habe und ich
weiß heute aus eigener Anschauung dass
diese Menschen mich niemals wie voll
nehmen werden
bin bald ein bestellter und ich bin der
Annahme des meine Chefs damit nicht dass
Duden würden und ich denke das sieht bei
meine Kollegen nicht das Verständnis
dafür haben deswegen möchte das eben für
meiden ich finde diese Beispiele und
Ergebnisse aus Studien zeigen deutlich
die sexuelle Orientierung spielt im
Arbeitsleben eine Rolle auch wenn sie es
nicht sollte kommen wir zum dritten und
letzten Punkt der rechtlichen
Gleichberechtigung hier gab es in den
letzten Jahren einen deutlichen
Fortschritt und die Ehe für alle war ein
besonderer Meilenstein doch der Weg
dahin war lang er begann mit der
Entkriminalisierung von Homosexualität
schauen wir einmal zurück in der Antike
war Homosexualität nicht strafbar mit
dem Aufkommen des Christentums in Europa
änderte sich die Moralauffassung im
Mittelalter wurden Homosexuelle
verbrannt im deutschen Kaiserreich hebt
man die Todesstrafe für Homosexuelle auf
führt stattdessen den Paragraphen 175
ein der die Bestrafung von homosexu mit
gefängnisvorschreibt
unter dem Nazi-Regime wurde das Gesetz
weiter verschärft die Zeit nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg Paragraf 175 behält in
der neu gegründeten Bundesrepublik seine
Gültigkeit und das bedeutet tausende
Männer werden jedes Jahr verurteilt im
Osten des Landes existierte der Paragraf
nicht mehr im Westen mussten
Homosexuelle weitere in strafrechtliche
Konsequenzen befürchten
1994 beschloss der Bundestag die
Streichung des Paragraphen doch erst
2017 wurden die Opfer die nach 1945 in
der Bundesrepublik verurteilt worden
entschädigt und rehabilitiert zwischen
einem und zehn Jahren Haft gab es für
die Umzug zwischen Männern beseitigen
heute ein großes Unrecht der deutschen
Rechtsgeschichte
der Paragraph 175 hat dazu geführt dass
nach 1945 in der Bundesrepublik über
70.000 Menschen verurteilt wurden nur
weil sie
homosexuell gewesen sind und ihre Liebe
auch gelebt haben ich wurde sehr oft als
Schwein betitelt dann damals und ich kam
mir wie so ein Schwein vor sich ich kam
mir so erniedrigt vor dass das hatte ich
so richtig verinnerlicht wenn ihr den
Beitrag über die Opfer von § 175 in
voller Länge sehen wollt schaut gerne in
der ZDF Mediathek vorbei auch lesbische
Frauen wurden verfolgt wenn auch weniger
öffentlich sichtbar es ist natürlich
eine lange Stigmatisierung der gerade
männlichen Homosexualität nicht der
weiblichen für die weibliche
Homosexualität hat sich eigentlich das
Recht nie interessiert die wurde
offensichtlich als ungefährlich
empfunden der zweite Schritt auf dem Weg
zur Ehe für alle war das
Lebenspartnerschaftsgesetz es wurde 2001
vor allem auf Drängen der Grünen
verabschiedet das
Lebenspartnerschaftsgesetz ermöglichte
es homosexuellen Paaren beispielsweise
einen gemeinsamen Nachnamen zu haben und
regelte das Erbrecht Gleichstellung
bedeutet er das aber nicht denn es
bestanden weiterhin Ungleichheiten vor
allem bei steuerrechtlichen Regelungen
und im Adoptionsrecht gegen eine
Gleichstellung also die Ehe für alle
sperrten sich vor allem cdu/csu
Tumi schwer damit und ich weiß dass ich
damit auch Menschen ihre Wünsche nicht
erfülle ich weiß dass das für viele
gleichgeschlechtliche Paare schwer ist
dann legte die damalige Bundeskanzlerin
Angela Merkel eine überraschende
Kehrtwende hin die sie mit einem
einschneidenden Erlebnis begründete
als ich plötzlich in meinem eigenen
Wahlkreis an der Ostsee mitbekommen habe
dass eine lesbische Frau zu mir gesagt
hat pass auf kommen Sie mal zu mir nach
Hause ich lebe damit meiner lesbischen
Partnerin und wir haben acht
Pflegekinder wenn der Staat zum Beispiel
sagt dass Jugendamt entscheidet ich kann
einer einem solchen paar Kinder zur
Pflege geben dann kann ich nicht mehr
ganz so einfach mit der Frage Kindeswohl
argumentieren deshalb möchte ich gerne
die Diskussion mehr in die Situation
führen dass wir dass das eher in
Richtung einer Gewissensentscheidung ist
sie erklärte die Abstimmung im Bundestag
über die Ehe für alle zur Gewissensfrage
damit entfiel also der Fraktionszwang
der die Abgeordneten an die Linie der
Parteiführung binden soll und
tatsächlich stimmte der Bundestag wenige
Tage nach Merkels Kehrtwende für die
Öffnung der Ehe für
gleichgeschlechtliche Paare Deutschland
war damit übrigens keineswegs Vorreiter
in Europa hatten es damals schon viele
andere Staaten gleichgeschlechtlichen
Paaren ermöglicht zu heiraten zuerst die
Niederlande 2001 trotz der Ehe für alle
sind homosexuelle rechtlich nicht
komplett gleichgestellt also ich glaube
sehr entscheidend ist erstmal sich
anzuschauen welche gesetzlichen
Regelungen es noch gibt die
diskriminierend sind ich sag mal zwei
Beispiele wenn ein Kind in eine Ehe mit
zwei Frauen hineingeboren wird hat es
rechtlich nur einen Elternteil die
andere Mutter muss adoptieren das ist
also für die Kinder weniger Schutz und
weniger Rechte und übrigens auch
diskriminierend ein weiterer Punkt sind
die Regelung zur Blutspende schwule
durften lange Zeit überhaupt nicht Blut
spenden das schlimmere ist eigentlich
die die
signalhaftigkeit bei der Bevölkerung
schwuder Sex ist krank inzwischen dürfen
schwule und bisexuelle männerblut
spenden wenn Sie in einer dauerhaften
monogamen Beziehungen leben die Frist
zur Zulassung einer Blutspende bei
sogenannten sexuellen Risikoverhalten
beträgt 4 Monate doch auch das ist aus
Sicht von Kritiker in diskriminierend
die Ampelkoalition hat sich vorgenommen
einiges für Quere Menschen zu tun sie
wollen zum Beispiel das Abstammungsrecht
von dem wir vorhin schon gehört haben
reformieren und auch die Regeln für
Blutspenden sollen geändert werden eines
der zentralen Vorhaben ist außerdem der
Nationale Aktionsplan gegen homo und
transfeindlichkeit den die Regierung
erarbeiten möchte wir wollen
verbindliche Maßnahmen auf den Weg
bringen damit halt eben wir eine
nachhaltig gutes Klima der Akzeptanz von
Vielfalt in der Bundesrepublik
etablieren die ampelregierung startete
also mit vielen queerpolitischen
versprechen und sie hat zumindest
gezeigt dass ihnen die lgbtqi Platz
Community wichtig ist beispielsweise
auch dadurch dass sie das neue Amt des
querbeauftragten geschaffen ob alle
Vorhaben auch umgesetzt werden ist
aktuell noch nicht abzusehen wo seht ihr
noch Handlungsbedarf und was muss ich
eurer Meinung nach dringend ändern
schreibt es mir gerne in die Kommentare
wenn ihr noch mehr Kontext sehen wollt
schaut euch gerne dieses Video von
meinem Kollegen Theo Koll an da fragt er
sich woher die Probleme der Deutschen
Bahn kommt und falls euch noch mehr
verschiedene Meinungen zur Ehe für alle
interessieren dann schaut mal hier
vorbei und natürlich nicht vergessen
unseren Kanal zu abonnieren